i
[Música]
ah
en perú el kobe 19 también se está
llevando a cuidados intensivos la
educación de los niños indígenas los más
afortunados tras recorrer algunos
kilómetros y subir elevadas colinas
pueden recibir señal de internet y
participar en las clases virtuales del
gobierno del universo de la población
estudiantil el ministerio de educación
revela que 230 mil escolares han salido
del sistema educativo y más de 200 mil
estudiantes no acceden a clases de
secundaria pese a estar matriculados
el problema se agrava más porque los
programas de educación virtual solo se
difunden en 10 de las 48 lenguas que se
hablan en el perú diversos colectivos
alertan que esta deficiencia afecta a
más de un millón de niños indígenas que
viven en zonas rurales se denuncia que
existirían comunidades que ni siquiera
sabían de la estrategia educativa del
gobierno como alternativa al cierre de
escuelas por la pandemia esto derivó a
los menores a atender tareas domésticas
y de pastoreo diversos especialistas
adelantan que la deserción escolar de
niños indígenas provocará más pobreza en
el futuro
[Música]
en méxico el modelo de clases por
televisión que se transmiten en señal
abierta gracias a un arreglo con
emisoras privadas no ha sido una opción
para miles de niños que se encuentran en
comunidades apartadas predominantemente
indígenas de estados como guerrero
oaxaca o chiapas y es que por ejemplo en
este último estado chiapas de acuerdo
con el instituto federal de
telecomunicaciones 37% de los hogares no
tiene acceso a una televisión en
guerrero es el 35 por ciento de
viviendas que se encuentran en nuestra
situación el gobierno contemplo clases a
través de la radio para aquellas zonas
donde no llega la señal televisiva y
diseñó programas en distintas lenguas
indígenas el problema es que en estados
como chiapas de acuerdo con el consejo
nacional de evaluación de la política de
desarrollo más de 65 mil personas en 1.2
por ciento de la población ya no digamos
señal de televisión no tienen siquiera
acceso a electricidad aquí las clases
por radio y tele no llegan y tienen que
recurrir a cuadernillos impresos para
que su aprendizaje en esta pandemia no
quede completamente en cero
[Música]
en bolivia desde que el gobierno
dispusiera la clausura del año escolar
la mayoría de los estudiantes ha quedado
en el limbo pues solamente los colegios
que pueden garantizar la educación
virtual están pasando clases los demás
han suspendido las labores educativas
donde la situación es más preocupante es
en el área rural donde miles de niños y
jóvenes indígenas no tienen ningún
acceso a la educación formal de hecho el
gobierno ha reconocido que uno de los
motivos para clausurar el año escolar es
que no existe acceso a internet en el
área rural también existe preocupación
porque los niños en la escuela recibían
el desayuno escolar y ahora ya no
tendrán ese beneficio lo que podría
provocar nuevos índices de desnutrición
en el país existen sin embargo algunas
iniciativas aisladas por ejemplo en el
municipio de copacabana en el
departamento de la paz
educadores aymara se están produciendo
piezas radiofónicas para que sus
estudiantes puedan pasar clases vía
radio al menos dos veces a la semana
[Música]